[Music]
henry
celia it's been a long time
they've opened the books on flight 127.
the hijackers had help from inside our
station here in vienna
we need to find out if we had a mold
[Music]
vic has me looking into flight 127. so
this is an interview
i thought you were here to see if we
still had that old spark
it's old friends
oh you can do better than that
it's old lovers
december 2012 paint me celia's picture i
was living the dream then flight 127
happened
the hijacking appears to have taken the
most tragic development someone in our
station betrayed us what about you
they cleared me
really
if we started shouting mo that would
have been it for all of us we look at
the evidence we follow the facts are you
accusing me
we want to keep this quiet we can't
afford the embarrassment of a
prosecution if it's celia harrison i
need to know the man i send can do
what's necessary
[Music]
got her right here in front of me i can
do this clean but it has to happen now
it's the things that we don't know that
get to me
[Music]
what we had was real
wasn't it
[Music]
you